I think that if you can convince people
of the power of Wolfram language and
convince them that to spend a little bit
of time learning it it'll pay off
tenfold my name is Andrew Yeol and I
work for a company called shirt flow
solutions and we work in the oil and gas
industry we're a team of engineers that
focus on solving production related
issues we do that through a couple of
different venues one is through modeling
software and performing simulations on
unfilled and another way is actually
looking at production chemistry we have
a production chemistry lab where we do
tests on oil samples and look for
specific production related issues the
Wolfram language for me personally
really comes in a lot on the back end of
that is analyzing that data post
processing that data doing you know
extra calculations on top of it and just
having a tool that allows me to
manipulate data a lot of data at one
time is really valuable
kind of the heart of what we tried to do
with it I think is solve a problem that
a lot of businesses face and that was
basically how do you capture your
company's intellectual property in a in
a consistent and maintainable way and
what we ended up using was the Wolfram
language to do exactly that
we have a project that we call Alex and
it was basically our attempt to try to
capture all of our previous knowledge
that was in the form of spreadsheets and
maintain it so that it was consistent
and that people knew exactly where they
could go to reach a particular type of
calculation that they wanted how I use
the Wolfram language daily its I use
things like Eclipse for the pure sort of
development and then we're more and more
starting to use the cloud as well most
send calculations to one another I'll
send something to a colleague we even
use the the cloud API to build small
little applications that our clients can
can utilize the Wolfram language on the
backend without necessarily knowing that
that's what they're doing
what's the ability to write you know one
line of code that I'll accomplish 10
things at once and and if you've ever
tried to do something like that in Excel
you you can't many times tools like the
Wolfram language offer a really powerful
alternative to things like Excel and I
think that if people were willing to you
know spend a little bit of time learning
what is out there and what it's capable
of I think those benefits would really
pay off